bonjour à tous cet après-midi les
sénateurs entament l'examen du projet de
loi sur la délimitation des régions en
clair sur la première partie de la
réforme territoriale sur la nouvelle
carte des super régions qui a été
présenté en Conseil des ministres
mi-juin un texte qui suscite beaucoup
d'opposition ici au Sénat que ce soit
dans la majorité ou dans l'opposition
puisque de nombreux sénateurs qui
représentent donc les élus locaux estim
que ces derniers n'ont pas été assez
consultés pour faire cette carte c'est
dans ce contexte que je vous propose de
voir ce matin et bien les travaux de la
Commission spéciale sur la réforme
territoriale une commission qui comme
son nom l'indique a été spécialement
conçue pour ce projet de loi qui
rassemble des sénateurs de tout bord et
de toutes les commissions la semaine
dernière ils ont auditionné de nombreux
experts de territoire des géographes des
démographes aussi des urbanistes c'est
cette audition que je vous propose de
revoir ce matin nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir alors je pas il y a pas
d'ordre de hiérarchie hein mais c'est
dans l'ordre où on on me l'a donné hein
donc Monsieur Patrick lelidc chargé de
recherche au
CNRS monsieur Gérard François Dumont
professeur à l'Université de Paris C
Sorbonne ancien recteur
oui recteur toujours on est toujours
recteur voilà mais la fonction voilà
c'est comme les préfet ça c'est comme
les Monsieur Philippe Subra professeur à
l'Université Paris 8 c'est ça monsieur
Hervé Lebras directeur d'études à
l'École des hautes études en sciences
sociales Monsieur Martin Vanier
professeur en géographie aménagement à
l'Université Joseph Fourier
Grenoble Monsieur Jacques levvy
professeur géographie d'aménagement de
l'espace à l'École polytechnique
fédérale de
Lausanne monsieur romain Pasquier
directeur de recherche au
CNRS et Monsieur Daniel Béard géographe
professeur à l'Institut d'Urbanisme de
Paris voilà merci messieurs d'être
venu donc vous savez que le Sénat pour
l'examen du texte portant de des
limitations des régions et ce
a décidé de créer une commission
spéciale et nous avons voulu regrouper
c'est pour ça que vous êtes nombreux à
la fois ceux qui devaient être audités
ou auditionnés je sais pas comment on
dit bon par la Délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et dans un
premier temps les auditions auxquelles
pensait procéder la commission des Lois
du Sénat puisavant que la Commission
soit char gé de ce texte la commission
spéciale la commission des lois qui
avait initié un petit peu voilà c'est
pourquoi vous êtes nombreux mais comme
vous êtes tous d'excellents spécialistes
et que vous êtes universitaire donc vous
êtes peu porté à
parler
longtemps n'est-ce pas il faut qu'on
tienne un petit peu dans des délais
raisonnables d'autant que nous avons ce
soir un texte qui n'est pas négligeable
en séance puisque mais qui ne concerne
pas du tout vos spécialités
puisque nous nous commençons à débattre
de du texte de Madame tobira sur la
contrainte pénale vous imaginez bien que
bah oui parce que ça au Sénat on
travaille contrairement à ce que
certains disent et pensent euh c'est on
travaille beaucoup donc je vous remercie
et bon et donc il nous a paru important
d'avoir l'avis des
spécialistes géographe euh et cetera euh
euh aménagement de de spécialiste de
l'aménagement
mais aussi parfois parce que de toute
façon on fait pas géographie sans faire
l'histoire jamais bon et donc sur bah
l'évolution des
régions comment vous voyez quels sont
pour
vous la pertinence de de ces grandes
régions hein de ces nouvelles
régions étant entendu que bien entendu
nous avons eu une étude d'impact
mais qui n'a pas forcément été faite par
des spécialistes en en urban en
aménagement du territoire et en
géographie voilà bien bon alors par
alors je commence je sais pas par quiin
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez une
idée pas bah on commence pas voilà hein
monsieur monsieur monsieur le liidc j'ai
bien dit il y a pas de hiérarchie hein
de toute
façon bien merci monsieur le président
peut-être une précision de méthode
combien de minutes est-ce que vous
m'accordez vous voyez on a un peu plus
de 1h 10 par là vous êtes 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 voilà ça fait 10 minutes quoi ça fait
10 bonnes minutes
m'excuse plus c questions
ça c'est impossible 5 minutes vous voyez
c'est pas possible faut pas
bien écoutez sur ce sur ce sur sur ce
texte je je m'étendrai pas longuement
sur la la question de la nécessité de la
la réforme territoriale parce qu'en fait
je pense que sur ce point il y a assez
largement un consensus sur le principe
d'une réforme on voit bien que le débat
se fait sur
disons les modalités avec une
multiplication de de de rapports et donc
la question n'est pas tellement est-ce
qu'il faut faire une réforme
territoriale mais plutôt laquelle et à
ce titre je pense qu'il y a quatre
quatre enjeux essentiels le premier
c'est évidemment l'approfondissement de
la décentralisation parce que
fondamentalement en 82 le législateur
n'a pas choisi entre en réalité trois
niveaux à l'époque et en fait quatre
niveaux de fait et donc on est en
réalité sur un système qui était en
réalité une vraie fausse
décentralisation puisqu'il y avait pas
de choix entre les niveaux pas
d'hérarchisation entre eux et donc pas
de véritable politique publique mais
plutôt un espèce de système de de
cogestion entre plusieurs niveaux entre
l'État et les collectivités également et
donc au fond d'une certaine manière ce
qu'on nous propose désormais il me
semble c'est en réalité de choisir et
sur ce point il me semble que le
dispositif proposé est relativement
intelligent parce qu'il il articule une
dévolution de l'autorité à un échelon et
en quelque sorte qui permettrait
d'atteindre une logique en réalité
d'ordre de mise en en ordre du système
territorial et puis la possibilité de
délégation de gestion à un autre ou à
plusieurs autres niveaux pour essayer de
surmonter la tension qui peut exister
entre la mise en cohérence qui est
nécessaire et en même temps rendu
problématique par notre principe de non
tutelle d'une collectivité sur une autre
et qu'intelligemment on s'efforce en
réalité de contourner en essayant de
trouver un moyen terme entre cette ce
souci de mise en ordre et le souci de la
proximité deuxième enjeu que je vois
c'est les enjeux budgétaires avec
évidemment à partir moment où on a un
émiettement de l'autorité entre un plein
de niveau de de de collectivité et au
sein en réalité de deux niveaux beaucoup
d'unités bah on a des des problèmes de
coût fixes qui sont liés à cette
émiettement et puis des coûts de
coordination qui sont extraordinairement
élevé ce qu'on appelle des coûts de
transaction en économie industrielle et
donc au fond
l'idée c'est plutôt de constituer des
des grands ensembles pour euh en quelque
sorte diminuer ces coûts de coordination
ces coûts de transaction qui sont très
élevés dans le système et de ce point de
vue-là je dirais euh autant d'ailleurs
pour le changement je m'éloigne
peut-être un peu du sujet de la maille
des interc mais
aussi de l'agrandissement des régions je
pense que ça va plutôt de ce point de
vue-là dans le bon sens l'enjeu étant
surtout de s'affranchir en fait des
microrégions ce que j'appellerais euh
les représentants mon mon voudront pas
des des régions bi ou tri
départementales et donc lorsqu'on
observe la carte qui est soumise au
débat en quelque sorte et bien on
observe que dans la plupart des cas il
s'agit essentiellement en quelque sorte
de regrouper les
petites régions entre elles plutôt que
de constituer des grandes avec de ce
point de vue-là quand même je dirais un
peu une exception euh qui est euh la
macroorégion midiyrénée long dooc sur
laquelle je
pense en tout cas ma conviction c'est
que éventuellement elle est peut-être un
peu trop grande sauf à ce que un
scénario sous-jacent soit présent qui
consisterait en réalité sur le
territoire de ces macrorégions à
péréniser l'échelon des assemblées
départementales même si peuvent évoluer
dans leur formes et dans les régions je
dirais de très petite taille et je pense
en particulier à la région norp decalais
qui pour l'instant reste un peu
orpheline on envisage une fusion
verticale avec les conseils généraux
comme ce pourrait-être le cas également
avec la Bretagne euh je pense qu'en tout
cas c'est une des lectures qu'on peut
faire euh je dirais de la carte qui est
euh
proposée le troisième enjeu que je vois
assez rapidement c'est l'adaptation au
fond aux évolutions sociales euh dans
une société qui est en fait une société
de mobilité et donc avoir de
microterritoires qui ne correspondent
pas en réalité aux aires de déplacement
des populations dans leur déplacement
quotidien domicile travail bah au fond
on voit bien que la journée de cheval
c'est plus tout à fait l'enjeu
aujourd'hui et de ce point de
vue-là encore une fois le problème dans
cette perspective qui serait
d'internaliser les externalités c'est de
constituer des très des trop grandes
région et donc c'est là aussi à nouveau
une nouvelle réserve sur la région
XXL étant entendu que on voit bien en
même temps que il y a eu un effort euh
euh qui ne pouvait être pas
nécessairement toujours satisfait de
constituer des régions autour de l'aire
de rayonnement de ce que le législateur
vient de consacrer avec la loi mpam du
27 janvier c'est-à-dire en réalité des
métropoles qui rayonnent sur leur
arrière-pays et vis-à-vis desquels il y
a évidemment une vocation de solidarité
qui doit s'exercer et de ce point de
vue-là la constitution de grande région
bah c'est justement une opportunité pour
réorganiser les fonctions de
redistribution à une échelle élargie
étant entendu que plus on accroit la
taille des circonscriptions fiscales
plus on résorbe mécaniquement les
inégalités qu'elles peuvent
receler le dernier etess de ce point de
vuel je dirais le 4e et dernier grand
jeu puisqu'il me semble que aujourd'hui
l'exercice de la fonction de solidarité
à une échelle strictement départementale
est plutôt un facteur d'inégalité qu'un
facteur d'égalité puisque là aussi la
littérature internationale nous enseigne
une chose très simple du point de vue du
ferradisme fiscal de ce point de vue-là
les conclusions sont toujours
convergentes c'est que les fonctions de
solidarité elles doivent s'exercer à une
échelle macro et donc le département
était bien une échelle macro au 18e ou
au 19e siècle malheureusement il ne pour
lui je dirais il ne l'est plus et
d'ailleurs on voit bien aussi que les
fonctions de solidarité d'une certaine
façon elles ne peuvent plus s'exercer
non plus à une Excel strictement
nationale elle va devoir être européenne
à partir du moment où il y a des
mobilité des entreprises à une échelle
européenne je crois que le même type de
raisonnement peut là très facilement
trouver à
s'appliquer dernier point peut-être sur
est-ce que au fond ce découpage régional
est le bon une fois on a dit qu'il a en
quelque sorte un sens de l'histoire à
élargir la taille des
circonscriptions le premier point de
méthode à rappeler c'est évidemment
qu'il y a pas de découpage qui ne fasse
de mécontent il y a forcément une part
d'arbitraire dans ces exercice là et en
1790 comme en 1956 lorsqu'on a découpé
les départements et les régions il y a
eu évidemment de très fortes
protestations puisque en réalité c'estes
redécoupagees et bien impacte la
hiérarchie des villes et donc il y a à
ce jeu-là des perdants et des gagnants
et on entendra surtout beaucoup euh les
perdants et donc au fond il est logique
que personne ne souhaite être relégué
aux périphéries euh au marges des
découpages on préfère être toujours au
cœur et si on avait donné le stylo euh
je dirais à l'ensemble des 550000 élus
locaux que la France compte chacun
aurait dessiné une carte au milieu de
laquelle il se serait trouvé euh le
deuxème élément bien sûr c'est que
quitte à se marier chacun souhaiterait
être marié avec un territoire riche
plutôt qu'avec un territoire pauvre et
on voit bien que de ce point de vue-là
chacun cherche à faire de beaux mariages
avec de bonnes bases fiscales et éviter
plutôt les voisins pauvres le problème
de cette pente là je dirais c'est que
elle est double le problème est double
c'est que d'un côté bah tout le monde va
vouloir se rattacher à l'île-de-fance et
dans ce cas-là on se retrouve avec la
France et donc on ne décentralise pas
euh et faute de cela ben on est toujours
probl confronté à un problème qu'on
pourrait appeler un problème
d'accommodement des des restes si j'ose
dire à partir du moment où on essaie de
construire une carte autour de l'aair de
rayonnement des métropoles et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quand on n pas de métropole
ben on peut dessiner des des des régions
avec effectivement des cheflieux qui
deviendront des métropoles parce qu'il
faut aussi penser en dynamique et voir
que à une échelle de 30 ou 40 ans je ne
sais pas tour par hasard pourrait euh
devenir et c'est un chef-lieu de de de
de de région euh dans un système
effectivement tel que en tout cas il a
été
esquissé 3è et dernier argument et je
m'en tiendrai là pour ne pas dépasser la
limite de temps qui m imparti c'est
l'argument de l'histoire et des
identités c'est évidemment un élément
important mais là encore je pense que il
faut relativiser la pertinence de
certains arguments par parce que
l'histoire en quelque sorte elle fait
son œuvre et la littérature du 19e elle
est pleine de critique sur
l'artificialité des découpages
départementaux et en même temps
aujourd'hui que voit-on même le
découpage de 64 bah les populations s'y
sont faites elles s'y sont attachées
preuve en est qu'on trouve même des
mouvements culturels qui défendent le 93
territoire qui était improbable mais qui
en même temps a acquis une identité et
donc de ce point de vue là B ce qu'on ob
c'est que ce sont en réalité les
institutions qui créent les identités et
pas l'inverse
merciieur alors Monsieur le Professeur
dont là il s'en va justqu au moment où
je vais
l'interviewer ah pardon ah ben je vous
en prie mais si vous voulez de l'eau m
moi j'ai de l'eau en plus he tenez
passer de l'eau
voilà ah bon fait dans l'ordre monsieur
Subra
allez allez-y il y a pas de querelle de
prééminence non non
oui alors évidemment après une première
intervention très complète et très
brillante nous allons certainement
redire un certain nombre de choses et en
même temps faire entendre chacun une
musique un petit peu différente c'est ce
qu'on attend absolument bon alors mais
mais il y aura des redites parce qu'il y
a des accords je pense entre entre nous
sur certains points la première remarque
que je voudrais faire c'est qu'il y a
une sorte de fantasme français du
découpage idéal qui va résoudre les
problèmes euh c'est certainement très
cartésien ça explique la la la
multiplication des
projets officiels ou officieux de
découpage qui ont exister depuis la fin
du 18e siècle et qui sont un jeu
extrêmement amusant pour un jeu
intellectuel extrêmement amusant à à
faire mais sans grandes conséquen euh il
y a il y a pas de découpage idéal
simplement parce que les régions ont des
fonctions toutes des fonctions qui sont
diverses c'est-à-dire une fonction de
cadre économique de réseau d'activité
une fonction de mise en œuvre de
politique publique mais aussi une
fonction identitaire sans oublier une
fonction politique c'est cadre de du
développement de carrière politique de
rapport de force électoraux entre les
partis qui explique en grande partie les
diff
à réformer mais je reviendrai sur les
trois premières ell ne coïncide pas
nécessairement c'est-à-dire un bon
découpage du point de vue identitaire
par exemple n'est pas nécessairement un
bon découpage du point de vue
fonctionnel celui de la mise en œuvre
des politiques publiques ni du point de
vue de l'économie locale de l'économie
territoriale où on a des réseaux qui
vont être plus petits ou être plus
grands que les régions identitaires ou
les régions
administratives donc ça c'est un premier
point ça veut dire que on on ne peut
viser que le meilleur ou le moins
mauvais des découpages mais aussi qu'il
faut être pragmatique et que dans
certains cas il faudra privilégier
l'aspect identitaire sur l'aspect
fonctionnel et dans d'autres cas
l'aspect fonctionnel sur l'aspect
identitaire ceci étant l'identité qui
est un pour moi un élément extrêmement
important probablement sous-estimé dans
le découpage qui a été proposé par le
gouvernement est aussi un facteur de
développement économique notamment dans
certaines régions où les réseaux
d'entreprises les réseaux
d'entrepreneurs les liaisons entre
entreprises grandes
écoles et
universités élus locaux vont faire que
se cré des dynamiques territoriales
extrêmement fortes donc ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut essayer de ne pas
casser dans la mesure du possible
deuxième remarque préalable on on on ne
cesse en France de raisonner par rapport
au modèle allemand il n'y a pas de
modèle allemand
satisfaisant pour nous comme référence
simplement parce que d'une part en
Allemagne mais ça c'est très connu vous
avez des lenders qui sont de taille
extrêmement diverses et que leur
histoire leur découpage s'explique par
des raisons
historiques accidentelle lié à
l'occupation au lendemain de la guerre
en grande partie deuxièmement parce
que les le modèle allemand est un modèle
fédéral ce n'est pas notre histoire et
décider d'aller vers une histoire
fédérale c'est un changement qui est
considérable ce n'est pas celui qui est
envisagé ça se manifeste notamment par
les moyens dont disposent les lenders et
la vraie question de ce point de vue ça
n'est pas la taille c'est la force de
frappe financière des lender et même si
on enlève ce qui relève des tâches de
l'enseignement qui sont fédérés et non
fédéral en Allemagne on a un budget
moyen pour un Land allemand qui est fois
celui d'une région française c'est là la
vraie différence et donc si on voulait
atteindre le même la même puissance de
frappe il faudrait qu'on ait un
découpage à deux
régions ce qui est évidemment pas
envisageable d'accord donc c'est là
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
important et puis
évidemment le la dernière raison pour ne
pas le considérer comme un modèle c'est
qu'il ne marche pas si bien que ça je
prendrai deux exemples celui d'un grand
investissement d'intérêt fédéral et
national
celui due nouvel aéroport de Berlin
brandbourg qui est une
faillitein un échec qui en France ferait
scandale et qui en Allemagne fait
scandale la deuxème le deuxème exemple
c'est celui de Hambourg dont la ville
land ne couvre que 40 % de
l'agglomération et qui a dû négocier
très longuement très lourdement pendant
3 ans un traité d'État avec les deux
lenders voisins pour mettre en place une
instance de gestion à l'échelle de l'IRE
urbaine donc ça n ça ne marche pas si
bien en Allemagne que ça bon alors
ensuite euh que pensez du découpage qui
est proposé je dirais qu'il a plusieurs
mérites don le principal c'est qu'il
nous évite les méga régions dont on
avait parlé à un moment donné type
circonscription des élections
européennes Grand Ouest Grand Est Grand
Sud-Ouest euh mer du mer du Nord manche
que sais-je
qui à la fois auraiit posé des problèmes
de fonctionnalité et notamment aurait
été à l'encontre d'un des objectifs de
la loi qui est de faire des régions qui
soient plus réactives qui soi source de
croissance économique dans un monde qui
est très concurrentiel qui est celui de
la mondialisation et de la concurrence
contre territoire faire des trop grandes
région c'est reproduire le modèle de
l'État à l'échelle
infranationale avec les mêmes distances
notamment entre porteur de projets et
centre de pouvoir de décision régionaux
et puis puis évidemment l'autre grand
défaut c'est la question identitaire
c'était mettre en place un découpage
donc une lecture du territoire national
sans racine sans affect sans réalité
pour identitaire pour une grande partie
de la population et là il y a un élément
dont on entend assez peu parler dans le
débat qui est celui du coup
politique électoral d'une telle réforme
Holland d'élection européennes qui ont
montré une demande d'État extrêmement
forte une demande de proximité de l'État
ou des services publ des pouvoirs et
aussi une demande de nation et de
référence identitaire et un rejet
d'Union Européenne perçu comme sans
racine trop éloigné et sans racine
bureaucratique technocratique donc il y
a un coup politique possible au niveau
électoral dans le sens d'une progression
du Front national si sil venait à
s'emparer de ce thème et pourquoi est-ce
qu'il ne le ferait pas qu'il ne faut pas
négliger
alors pour terminé parce que je pense
que je suis presque à la fin de mon
temps de parole
euh je suis évidemment d'accord avec les
critiques qui ont été faites au
découpage d'un certain nombre de régions
notamment la Grande Région faite des
chutes du découpage euh
oui
ben c'est un patchwork fait avec des
chutes et euh c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui n'est pas acceptable il faut
que le travail parlementaire aboutissent
en partie à un un un nouveau dessin de
la carte supprimant cette région qui n'a
pas de sens ni d'organisation ni
d'identité regroupant autrement les
régions qui ont été regroupées ainsi
dans cette grande région et puis je
dirais qu'il y a un autre élément qui me
paraît très criticable c'est le principe
qu'a affiché dès le départ le
gouvernement de ne pas toucher aux
régions mais simplement aux limites mais
simplement de les regrouper de les
marier ce qui aboutit à un certain
nombre d'incohérence je pense que
notamment il fa il faut toucher à la
région
Picardie il faut que l'Oise qui est une
très grande banlieue de Paris rentre
dans la région Île-de-France il faut que
la somme hline soit répartie autrement
vers le nordpcalais vers la
champagnearden euh
là il y a il y a il y a un choix de
départ qui est justifié par des raisons
je dirais tactiques
éviter d'ouvrir la poettete de Pandore
et et d'aller vers des débats sans fin
mais je rappellerai simplement que le le
précédent grand découpage qui a eu lieu
celui des
départements qui a
révolutionné la carte territoriale
française a pris 6 mois de débat avec
des délégations qui venaient de petit
ville expliquer bien nous avons nos
habitudes en terme de judiciaire le
bailli en termes commerciaux et nous
voulons être attaché et avec tout en en
conservant un certain nombre de
principes de départ et bien il y a eu
des accomodements il faut que le travail
parlementaire permette des modifications
à la marge des limites qui euh fassent
qui aboutissent un découpage qui tiendra
la route parce que ce découpage
Parlement départemental il a fait ses
preuves il est toujours en place
aujourd'hui il a comme mon prédécesseur
l'expliqué il a il a généré des
identités forte aussi artificielle qu'il
ait pu être perçu au départ et donc
c'est un bon découpage il a peut-être
fait son temps mais il a joué son rôle
et il faut s'inspirer de cette
méthode merci je pense que le professeur
Lebras ne vous démentira pas sur votre
conclusion absolument ça viendra et ça
viendra dans ma conclusion aussi pour
d'autres raisons d'ailleurs je vais être
aussi peut-être un peu plus rapide
puisque un certain nombre de choses qui
ont été
dites correspondent tout à fait à mon
sentiment j'insisterai peut-être
justement sur pour finir deux points où
je serais en
léger désaccord avec mes prédécesseurs
d'abord moi il me semble que la première
chose à faire avant le le découpage
c'était de redéfinir les compétences je
crois que tout le monde il y avait un
accord très large et il me semble qu'un
découpage est la conséquence d'une
redéfinition des des compétences alors
admettons quand même que tel que c'est
dit ce cette redéfinition des
compétences donne la compéten économique
au sens large aux régions donc est-ce
que quel quel critère adopté pour faire
un découpage partant de ce postulat sur
l'économie quand on on lit le texte qu'a
envoyé le président Hollande au journaux
il y a deux arguments seulement une
taille européenne et ça permettra de
bâtir des stratégies territoriales alors
il y a un troisième argument mais je
vous le je le laisse pour la fine bouche
qui est pourquoi
doit-on se presser l'argument c'est euh
il nous faut aller vite euh car il ne
faut aller vite car il ne nous est pas
permis de tergiverser c'est pas une
explication donc je laisserai cet
argument de côté pour alors la taille
européenne mon prédécesseur a très bien
dit avec grande justesse
qu'effectivement on est de toute manière
de taille européenne et que si on prend
le cas de l'Allemagne si souvent
cité je vous signale qu'actuellement sur
les 16 régions allemande h d'entre elles
donc la moitié sont moins peuplé que la
plus petite
des régions françaises qui a été découpé
je peux je peux pas vous donner la liste
mais on tombe à des chiffre souvent bas
de l'ordre de 600000 ou de 1 million
d'habitants là on peut en faire la liste
assez rapidement donc l'argument de
taille européenne à mon avis n'est n'est
parcevable assez curieusement on il y a
une sorte de sentiment égalitaire en
France où il faudrait de la même manière
qu'on voulait que les départements
soient des carrés de 18 lieux de côté on
voudrait je crois que les régions soient
toutes égales c'est utopique il y a
l'histoire il y a l'économie il y a
surtout l'économie alors c'est un autre
point alors un initier des
stratégies bâtir des stratégies
territoriales j'ai trouvé le terme assez
dur parce que justement il me semble que
les régions qui ne disposent pas d'un
énorme budget en France ont été
audacieuses du point de vue des
stratégies que elles ont batti du moins
pour un certain nombre d'entre elles que
je connais j'ai j'ai une certaine
admiration je trouve que ce qui a été
fait en midiipyrénée ce qui a été fait
en L crousillon ce qui a été fait en
Pays de la Loire avec le numérique et
les robots et ainsi de suite pas toutes
mais ça ça existe si vous voulez et je
trouve qu'on a pas tenu compte justement
de l'existant autre chose dont on n pas
tenu compte et dont il vient d'être
question il me semble que il y a un
certain archaïsme à penser en terme de
de découpage et de frontière parce que
ce qui existe maintenant c'est les grand
ville c'est les métropoes et donc il
faudrait au fond articuler et après tout
il y a une loi qui est la loi Mapam qui
est passé le je crois le 19 décembre
dernier donc le minimum aurait été de me
semble-t-il d'articuler ces métropoes
ces 12 métropoles choisies on pouvait
d'ailleurs discuter le choix je vais en
dire un mot mais là je n'ai vu aucune
articulation certaines des régions
proposées ont deux métropoles parmi les
12 d'autres en ont une et d'autres
autres en ont aucune donc là il y a je
pense qu'il y a une absence de cohérence
et c'est d'autant plus grave que
justement ce qui fait une région il me
semble du point de vue économique c'est
une cohérence notamment une cohérence de
son réseau urbain les géographes je
pense en parleront plus que moi mais
totalement de ce qu'on appelle la
géographie la hiérarchie urbaine ou bien
la géographie de commandement j'ai été
un grand défenseur la région des Pays de
la Loire qui certes n'a pas ne date pas
du tout de du très fond de l'histoire
mais qui a une extraordinaire cohérence
du point de vue de sa hiérarchie urbaine
Nant est une une métropole anger et
leement sont des grandes villes et puis
on passe à des villes un peu plus
petites puis un tissu de de de villes
appelons les moyennes mais qui va de
châteaubillant à sa mur en passant par
choletis c'est bien fait si vous voulez
c'est et je trouve pas que on est mieux
fait plutôt le contraire dans la carte
actuelle alors un mot sur la carte
actuelle je en fait à part la fusion
HauteNormandie Basse Normandie et encore
est-ce que c'est pas qu'Al mot Normandie
parce que rien n'y prédispose
véritablement et puiselle Bourgogne et
franchecé
oui pourquoi pas alors pour faire une
région forte comme l'a dit Claudie le
Breton une fois c'est pas en mettant
deux régions faibles qu'on obtient
nécessairement une région forte ça me
semble là aussi du bon sens mais sinon
les autres groupements je seraai assez
critique parce que langdoc et midi
Pyréné là c'est vraiment un regroupement
mystérieux puisque les spécificités
économiques des deux et les efforts
économiques de Montpellier de Toulouse
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes c'est il y
a d'un côté un un développement à
montpolier qui est fort dans les
notamment dans l'agronomie et dans une
partie de fond de qui touche à à de la
biologie qui d'ailleurs peut s'articuler
sur Marseille et puis bien sûr Toulouse
très cohér de façon très cohérente
jusqu'à la mécanique vallée c'est un
développement sur
le sur tout ce qui est avion et puis
tout ce qui est hélicoptère spatial donc
là je vois pas je vois pas la la
signification je vois pas comment on va
trancher et je me dis j'ai fait une
remarque un petit peu perfide j'ai dit
si George frache était vivant je suppose
qu'on aurait pas fait le même découpage
bon euh Picardie champagne alors là on
on sent on approche des des régions on
approche du traitement des résidus d'
certaine manière parce que je pense que
il y a je vois aucun je vois aucun
rapport entre le plateau de langangre et
la Bête somme et puis en plus de ça les
deux capitales sont si bien salon surmne
et et puis Amien alors on va être obligé
de mettre un comme capitale c'est bien
d'ailleurs c'est la plus grande ville
mais on va sans doute construire un un
hôtel régional à 80 millions comme à
cliremference qui va limiter quand même
les gains économiques qu'on attend de de
cela donc là cette région m'a paraît
bizarre centre Limousin Poitou oui là
vous en avez parlé c'est la voiture
Balet hein c'est on ramasse ce qui ce
qui reste sur sur le terrain j'attirerai
vre attention sur un dernier point je
suis et mais ça ça rejoint la question
des métropoles il me semble à voir à
connaître la carte de de France que
c'est dommage de de mettre hor circuit
clairmontferrand parce que c'est la
seule grande ville sur un énorme espace
quand on regarde elle c'est vraiment
tout ce centre de de la France vous
trouvez pas de de grande villes avant
justement Lyon avant Paris avant Nantes
avant Bordeaux il y a un énorme espace à
animer il me semble que cler
mononttferrand bien sûr n'a pas tout à
fait la taille d'une métropole mais je
pense que c'est assez dangereux de
laisser tomber tout cet énorme centre de
la France parce que le rattachement à je
sais bien que les industriels de
Clermont sont plutôt pour le
rattachement je pense que les maires des
petites communes sont plutôt contre donc
il y a du pour et du contre mais il me
semble que d'un point de vue au fond là
de maîtrise du territoire clermot
Ferrand aurait pu être aurait pu garder
un certain point l'économie ben on en
d'autres en parleront mieux que moi j'ai
vu une étude intéressante qui a été
faite il y a 5 ans par un groupe qui
s'appelle esprit public une étude de
mouterde sur le coût et les gains du
regroupement HauteNormandie basse
norormandie donc bien avant qu'on en
parle il faudrait 8 ans pour que arriver
à du avoir un bénéfice et le bénéfice
serait de 04 % du budget donc vous
pouvez l'étude est consultable sur
Internet c'est vraiment une étude
sérieuse les coû déménagement c'était
très bien fait hein bon mais je n'ai pas
d'autres études peut-être que c'est
seulement pour les deux Normandies que
ça se passera pas très efficacement les
départements deux mots sur les
départements identité les départements
c'est là que je m'écarterai un peu du du
premier orateur je pense quand on voit
une carte carte de France c'est la la
bonne échelle pour la mixité sociale
c'est-à-dire que vous prenez les les si
vous une carte de France vous prenez si
je pourrais vous en j'aurais pu vous en
projeter une mais vous prenez les
préfectures ou les bon disons les
cheflieux de
département presque sans exception ou
laissons de côté 3 qu cas c'est les les
revenus médiens les plus élevés c'est la
plus forte proportion de cadre c'est la
plus forte proportion de profession
intermédiaire parmi les cadres et les
profession intermédiaires c'est les plus
diplômés des cadres et des professions
intermédiaires c'est le plus faible
nombre des sans diplômes on peut
continuer et plus on s'éloigne du
cheflieu de département plus ces
critères baissent et on arrive aux
frontières des départements qui sont des
zones sur lequelles se concentre en
général B pas forcément exactement les
difficultés mais la tenenie et j'avais
fait il y a quelques temps une étude sur
quelle était la proportion de lit
personnes âgé dans l maison de retraite
dans par commune j'avais tracé une carte
avec les données des affaires sociales
et ça sortait presque la carte des
frontières des départements et c'est
assez logique parce que c'est un peu des
zones de rejet donc il me semble que
garder les départements ça permet une
mixité ça permet d'avoir ensemble les
les plus riches et les plus pauvres à
une échelle qui est encore une échelle
raisonnable alors que je pense que si on
se met au niveau des intercommunalité et
bien il y en a qui seront riches et
d'autres pauvres on n'aura pas ce niveau
de mixité et si on se met au niveau des
région bon on gagne pas grand-chose par
rapport à la au département il y a un
éloignement qui est plus plus fort donc
c'est une des raisons de ma ma défens
des départements mais elle n'est pas
économique elle est sociale je pense que
retirer les compétences économiques des
départements est plutôt quelque chose de
bon sens mais socialement j'ai
l'impression et puis ce qui a été dit
fort justement c'est euh que ils ont
modelé un espace ils ont modelé un
espace social peut-être au moins autant
que culturel un dernier mot sur
l'identité parce que avec mon nom breton
j'ai j'ai été sollicité pour le 5e
département de Bretagne et j'étais
extrêmement hostile à cette idée d'abord
parce qu'elle pose de très gros problèm
qui sont le choix entre reine et Nantes
qui n'est pas du tout évident et puis
ensuite parce que je ces questions
d'identité sont très souvent des
questions de du passé et puis enfin
justement comme breton je connais la
Bretagne et c'est un pays qui est
extrêmement différent c'est un pays
quand vous regardez les caractéristiques
de la Bretagne dite maritime donc les
trois départements euh morbid enfin pas
complètement disons vous tracez une une
ligne entre Vanes et saint-briux tout ce
qui est à l'Ouest c'est assez différent
et même très différent c'est le pays
breton le tout ce qui est à à à l'est
c'est le pays gallo qui a une histoire
plus proche à la limite même de cette
fois-là de la la Mayenne donc l'identité
de bretonne me semble pas une une chose
à encourager et personnellement je crois
que c'est une chance de la France que
que de ne pas de ne pas être confronté à
des problèmes régionalistes graves comme
on en rencontre je vais pas vous
énumérer la Flandre la Catalogne
l'Écosse j'ai vu que la vénée voulait
voulait son indépendance maintenant là
là donc si on peut éviter ça et c'était
il faut se souvenir qu'en
1789 il y avait un côté esprit des
lumières avec la trame carré mais il y
avait aussi un côté table des divisions
du du passé et ça a été très très
habilement fait donc je me séparerai sur
la question d'identité un petit peu de
mes prédécesseurs du moins dans ce cas
breton je vous remercie de votre
attention mer monsieur professeur alors
Monsieur Jacques LV bonjour merci de
nous
écouter bon j'ai j'ai le sentiment qu'il
y
a il y a beaucoup de malentendu à la
fois sur les enjeux les visés la méthode
dans dans ce qui est en train de se
passer néanmoins je voudrais quand même
signaler que enfin ce que tout le monde
a remarqué même si c'est pour des
raisons d'opportunités politiques assez
complexes
euh on est peut-être en train d'assister
à une mise en mouvement des
territoires celle qui a eu tant de mal à
à arriver peut-être qu'on est en train
je sais pas si je dois être optimiste
euh mais de
lever les deux malédictions finalement
qui ont qui ont pesé sur l'architecture
des territoires en France celle de la 3e
république qui a qui a figé qui a
congelé en fait le projet
révolutionnaire qui était extrêmement
dynamique qui était fédéral d'ailleurs
on faête vous le savez le 14 juillet la
fête de la Fédération et non pas la
prise de la Bastie donc l'idée que la
France soit une fédération n'est pas
scandaleuse à mes yeux en tant que
Français républicain et donc on a
congelé tout ça en créant une alliance
entre d'un côté les notables R qui était
très puissant à l'époque et l'État
central et on a on a fabriqué la machine
du département qui ne pouvait plus
bouger dont les cantons ne pouvaient
plus bouger et qui au fil de
l'urbanisation s'est transformé en un
système fiscal bon j'ésite en PL mot ici
mais c'est pour être plus imagé une
espèce de raquette des des campagnes
donc en fait maintenant du Péré urbain
sur les villes puisque vous savez qu'il
y a un département il y a un canton qui
est 47 fois plus petit que le plus grand
du département ça veut c'est comme si on
bourrait les urnes c'estàd si des gens
avaient 47 vois chaque fois qu'il votait
donc ça c'est en train de changer hein
d'ailleurs on en a parlé un peu moins
mais alors je sais pas si le département
disparaît ça aussi va disparaître mais
même s'il ne disparaît pas il s'est
passé enfin avec la mise en place un peu
c'est un tour de prestigitation assez
amusant puisque on met en place un un
système électoral particulièrement
injuste avec un système de uninominale
mais à deux deux postes pour obtenir la
parité mais en même temps on on va
égaliser un peu la population des des
cantons pas un peu beaucoup on va
appliquer des principes disons
démocratiques enfin sur ce dans ce
domaine donc ça c'est une mise en
mouvement l'autre mise en mouvement qui
qui est très très lente et qui d'une
certaine façon fait un pas en avant de
pas en arrière c'est la construction
d'un espace de gouvernement urbain donc
le l passage d'intercommunalité à des
véritables gouvernements urbains à
l'échelle des des grandes ires urbaines
qui comme vous le savez dans un espace
presque totalement urbanisé sont
vraiment maintenant l'armature de base
de l'espace français he il y a
effectivement donc c'est souvent des
chefliux de département Hervé Lebas a
raison mais c'est souvent des plus
grandes villes donc c'est cet archipelle
de villes plus ou moins importantes qui
regroupe la plupart de la population qui
produisent de très loin l'essentiel de
de la production en France c'est là où
sont les le plus souvent localisés les
industries créatives donc c'est bien sûr
autour d'elle qu'on doit organiser
l'espace français pas pour leur donner
un privilège mais pour que tous les
Français aient le droit d'accès à ces
ressourcesl ce qui nous amène au 3oème
niveau mais avant je dis quelle est la
deuxième malédiction qu'on va peut-être
lever c'est celle de la des lois de
décentralisation de 1980 de parce que là
en
prétendant moderniser
l'architecture territoriale française en
fait on l'a en partie modernisé mais sur
la base de situations qui étaient
archaïque notamment en renforçant les
niveaux qui n'avait plus lieu d'être
déjà à cette époque qui était la commune
c'est-à-dire des morceaux de ville et le
département dont j'ai parlé donc en fait
on a accumulé des problèmes on a
accumulé des handicaps et c'est vrai que
du coup c'est de plus en plus difficile
de faire des réformes hein c'est encore
plus difficile aujourd'hui que en 1982
il y avait eu des discussions d'ailleurs
dans l'équipe de François mitteran il a
à mon avis il a fait le mauvais choix et
du coup on paye aussi cette
accumulation d'il a d'il y a quelques
décennies donc le le 3è niveau
effectivement enfin 2è niveau
fonctionnel avec les aires urbaines
c'est la région et il me semble que on
peut se représenter enfin les
comparaisons avec le découpage des
départements de 1789 sont assez justifié
c'était les régions de l'époque en fait
et simplement
euh on n'est plus un pays rural mais un
pays urbain donc il y a des métropoles
qui structure de façon réticulaire
beaucoup plus que territoriale l'espace
français il y a une mobilité et et donc
il faut tenir compte dans les aménités
qu'on offre aux habitants le fait qu'ils
peuvent bouger euh et par ailleurs il y
a il a une connexion au monde extérieur
et donc le fait d'être une métropole
c'està dire en fait dans l'esprit
courant quand on quand on dit ce mot une
connexion au reste du monde qui est
importante et du coup la métropole c'est
une
ressource que un
individu un un citoyen français doit
pouvoir avoir à sa disposition s'il veut
déployer son intelligence sa créativité
à l'échelle de sa vie et c'est là à mon
avis le premier principe de découpage
des régions la région c'est un espace
biographique c'est est-ce que moi
habitant d'un point du territoire je
vais avoir à ma disposition un éventail
d'opportunité qui va me permettre de
réaliser ce que ce que je peux faire de
d'intéressant dans ma vie d'où le fait
ça a été dit par plusieurs euh par par
par mes trois prédécesseurs que la
région c'est un point d'équilibre entre
des ressources objectives et des
ressources subjectives c'est-à-dire en
gros les métropoles je simplifie en
disant les ressources objectives parce
qu'il y en a d'autres mais quand même
les métropoles c'est le gros morceau et
des ressources subjectifes qui sont les
identités qui sont pas forcément figé
hein bon Hervé Lebas a raison de dire
que euh c'est pas enfin faut pas les
mytifier il est méchant avec la
Normandie mais mais il a pas tort quand
on quand on va à camp on sait très bien
que les canais n'ont pas trop envie de
d'être avec les rouanais ou avec les
Avrais donc et et tous ces toutes ces
métropoles euh qui sont des fantasmes de
technocrates qui qui sont vieilles déjà
qui des métropoles en réseau du genre
tour Orléan Ren Nantes mesnancy ça
suffit pas queil y ait pas beaucoup de
kilomètres entre elles pour que ça
marche hein
donc je pense que ces questions
identitaires qui d'ailleurs ne ne sont
pas hors sol qui correspondent c'est
c'estes couples de ville elles sont
souvent des couples ce sont souvent des
couples de villes rivales qui ont été
construits pour ça par ceux qui les ont
mise en place souvent une ville
épiscopale et une ville
euh de seioriale ou ou de pouvoir
centrale
monarchique donc donc voilà il il y a
des réalités alors je reprends tout ce
qui a été dit sur le fait que la taille
n'est pas un bon fantasme de la même
manière que c'est pas le sujet mais que
pour les universités hein les
technocrates français sont les seul à
croire que seul les grandes universités
réussissent il y a qu'à voir le ranking
tous les rankings c'est des universités
qui sont toutes plus petites que la plus
petite des universités françaises qui
sont en tête et bien pour les régions
c'est pareil il y a aucune raison de
croire que une petite région ne peut pas
réussir par exemple l'Alsace dont on
parle pas beaucoup si on l'associe à la
laorine pourquoi pas mais c'est un
cadeau à la Lorine en fait parce que
l'Alsace se débrouille très bien toute
seule elle se débrouillerait encore
mieux si on avait pas fait une loi un
peu bizarre pour empêcher les
départements de fusionner mais mais ça
marche le Nord Pas De calé ça marche et
et la Corse effectivement beaucoup
d'identité peu de
métropole ça marche peut-être pas très
bien pour le moment mais c'est sûr que
c'est comme ça que ça va marcher si ça
doit marcher et donc personne
heureusement ne veut fusionner la Corse
avec la
Picardie peut-être oui oui il y a
peut-être une place à prendre voilà
ouais ouais ouais donc donc il me semble
que que là il y a comment dire c'est pas
un jeu de construction c'est pas un jeu
de mécano et là le malentendu c'est que
souvent on comme ça s'est fait dans la
précipitation que on n pas d'abord pris
le temps de de réfléchir et Philippe
Subra a justement parler du travail
parlementaire mais je pense que ça va
au-delà pour un changement
civilisationnel comme celui-là il me
semble qu'il aurait il aurait fallu
faire les choses dans l'ordre
c'est-à-dire d'abord engager un grand
débat national pas seulement avec les
élus parce qu'évidemment les élus ont
aussi des intérêts on s'en est bien
aperçu dans les petites négociations qui
ont déjà eu lieu entre amis surtout
celle entre amis euh et et donc ça
personnellement dans le livre que j'ai
publié il y a un an je propose qu'on
mette en place un Haut Conseil des
territoires qui ne comprenne pas
d'élus qui comprennent les éléments de
la société ça veut pas dire ce ce ce
conseil ça serait comme le le Comité
national d'éthique qui n'aurait pas un
pououvoir il n'aurait pas un pouvoir
décisionnel bien sûr c'est la
représentation nationale qui trancherait
mais c
cet organisme il aurait la la mission de
dire l'état actuel de la société et les
acteurs ils ont des tas d'idées sur le
sujet ils ont des réseau complexe et
donc voilà il me semble que en gros donc
je je termine si vous prenez d'un
côté le présent et le futur c'estàdire
quel est l'état actuel et vers quoi on
pourrait tendre vers quel projet on
pourrait aller et d'autre part
ressources objectiv ressources subjectiv
vous avez un tableau quatre cases et il
me semble que c'est ça le tableau de
bord du découpage en général juste un
point concret pour terminer dans cet
esprit si on si on part des métropoles
et qu'on se
demande comment faire vivre le droit à
la métropole il serait absolument
logique de la même manière qu'on a
associé l'Auvergne à la région Ronal
donc de dire l'Auvergne a droit à la
métropole lyonnaise il serait logique
que l'Île-de-France cesse d'être une
région parce que c'est un espace
métropolitain c'est une métropole c'est
une aire urbaine c'est un réseau de
transport c'est un marché de l'emploi
c'est un marché du logement et donc il
faudrait faire que la région
Île-de-France soit la métropole
parisienne et non pas ce petit morceau
qu'on a qu'on a découpé encore un
arrangement entre amis et que par
ailleurs on est une région de Paris qui
se corresponde logiquement bon Lyon
c'est à peu près de millions d'habitants
la région Ronal plus auverne elle est
elle correspond à ce poid la région qui
correspondra
avec Paris ça serait en gros le Bassin
parisien donc il me semble que c'est
dans cette optique là on aurait une
région qui serait à peu près du poids de
Renan du Nord vestphali et la Corse
c'est comme la SAR donc voilà ça marche
merci merci Monsieur le Professeur alors
Monsieur le Professeur Gérard François
Dumont monsieur Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je vous remercie
d'abord de cette audition j'ai certaines
convergence avec mes collègues mais
peut-être davantage de divergence je
voudrais d'abord simplement rappeler
puisque c'est le centenaire de
l'assassinat de Jean jorè qui nous a
laissé une phrase essentielle aller à
l'idéal et comprendre le réel donc si je
regarde la propos le projet de loi
pardon qui vous a été présenté il y a
deux idéau qui sont évoqué dans le
projet de loi premièrement arrivver à
une taille critique sur le plan
géographique démographique et économique
et et deuxièmement faire des économies
donc la question qui se pose c'est de
savoir si ces idéaux qui sont exprimés
dans le projet de loi sont fondés sur la
compréhension du réel donc je vous
propose d'examiner d'abord la taille
critique puis ensuite la question des
économies avant de vous proposer
quelques conclusions donc en page 3 il
est évoqué d'abord la taille critique
sur le plan géographique comme certains
de mes collègues l'ont l' rappeler la
plus petite des régions françaises de
métropole continentale c'est l'Alsace or
on trouve beaucoup de régions dans les
autres pays européens qui ont des
dimensions nettement moins importantes
que celles de l'Alsace et même lorsqu'on
parle de l'Italie en névoquant que trois
régions qui seraient plus petites que
l'Alsace en réalité il faut rappeler
quand même que le trenttin et le oadig
sont tous les deux des provinces
autonomes équivalents à des régions donc
on a bien cinq régions en réalité en
Italie qui sont plus petites que
l'Alsace et il faut noter que ces petite
taille ne sont pas nécessairement des
handicaps puisque lorsqu'on regarde les
taux de chômage ou les taux d'emploi de
ces régions il n'y a pas de corrélation
entre la taille géographique et les
résultats économiques de ces régions
concernant donc les régions françaises
vous savez que les pluivases sont donc
minipyénées et ronalp il faut préciser
que ce sont de vastes régions puisque
chacune d'entre elles ont une superficie
plus grande que la Belgique plus grande
que le Luxembourg bien entendu plus
grande que la Suisse et plus grande que
le Danemark donc ce ne sont pas des
tails
géographiques petite et de toute façon
déjà si on considère nos 21 régions de
France métropole continentale elles ont
une superficie moyenne qui est
supérieure à celle des landur Allemands
2uxè élément le taille critique sur le
plan démographique sur le plan
démographique donc la région la moins
Pelé de France métropolitaine
continentale c'est le Limousin avec
742000 habitants est-ce en Europe une
petite taille la réponse est non dans la
mesure où nous avons de nombreuses
régions dans les autres pays d'Europe en
Italie en Espagne en Allemagne et bien
sûr les cantons Suisse dont le nombre
d'habitants est nettement inférieur à
celui du
Limousin et si je considère la moyenne
des régions des 21 régions de France
continentale métropolitaine cela
représente donc 3 millions d'habitants
hein c'est un chiffre qui est supérieur
à la moyenne des régions italiennes
c'est un chiffre qui est certes
inférieur à la moyenne des Landers
allemands mais il faut se rappeler que
la l'Allemagne a une histoire
démographique totalement différente de
celle de la France puisque la France a
baissé sa fécondité dès la fin du 18e
siècle et non dès la fin du 19e siècle
et donc si le rythme de fécondité de la
France avait été le même que celui
d'Allemagne le poids démographique de
nos régions serait évidemment beaucoup
plus important donc il s'agit d'un
nombre moyen d'habitants des régions
françaises qui est supérieur également à
aux communautés autonomes de l'Espagne
aux régions polonaise et si je regarde
les États-Unis j'ai quand même 20 États
sur les 50 qui ont moins de 3 millions
d'habitants donc une taille inférieure à
la taille moyenne des régions françaises
3ème élément donc dans ce rapport page
34 on nous fait comprendre que l'un des
soucis du projet de loi c'est de
parvenir à des ensembles plus homogènes
en terme de population donc il s'agirait
de considérer que le fait qu'il y ait
une fourchette relativement large entre
les les la région la plus peuplée la
région la moins peuplée serait un
handicap pour l'attractivité des
territoires français et donc que la
France pastirait de cette
différence alors effectivement euh sans
avant même de regarder les chiffres on
pourrait penser que la France serait
très hétérogène tout simplement parce
que la France a une politique
centralisatrice tant du temps des rois
qu'après ce que montre bien soit le
réseau des roules royales soit après le
réseau ferroviaire rayonnant depuis
Paris et donc que la France est en fait
avec l'Angleterre et Londres le seul
pays européen qui a une région au monde
qui est l'île de France donc cela
évidemment donne une taille
significative qui pourrait conduire au
fait que les fourchettes d'écart entre
les régions les plus peuplées et les
moins peuplées serait tout à fait
considérable or il n'en est rien si je
regarde le rapport des populations entre
les 21 régions actuelles j'ai un rapport
de 1 à 7
si je mets à part l'Île-de-France ce que
propose parfois d'ailleurs votre projet
de loi j'ai un rapport qui est de 1 à 8
quels sont les rapports dans les autres
pays européens voisins bien ils sont
beaucoup plus élevés le rapport en
Allemagne est de 1 à 27 le rapport en
Espagne est de 1 à 26 le rapport en
Italie entre la région la moins peuplée
la région la plus peuplée et de 1 à 76
et si je vais outre atlantique
le rapport entre les 50 états est de 1 à
66 donc vous voyez que il n'y a pas
d'hétérogénéité particulière dans les
différences de taille démographique des
régions dans les territoires français si
nous examinions la superficie nous
arrivions nous arriverions pardon
exactement au même résultat les écarts
de superficie des 21 régions de France
métropolit continentale vont de 1 à 5 si
je vais en Allemagne je vais de 1 à
174 en Espagne de 1 à 19 et je je prends
évidemment que les régions d'Espagne
continentale he je ne prends pas les
deux archipeles si je vais en Italie
j'ai un rapport de 1 à 8 donc le l'idée
d'homogénéité qui est évoqué dans le
rapport ne me paraît pas correspondre à
la juste compréhension du réel 3è
élément de l'argumentation une taille
critique sur le plan économique et pour
cela donc le rapport en particulier je
crois page 34 explique que si on
fusionne un certain nombre de régions on
va avoir une plus grande homogénité dans
le Produit Intérieur Brut par habitant
par région en réalité je dirais qu'en
géographie c'est pratiquement une
tothologie c'est-à-dire à partir du
moment effectivement qu'on diminue le
nombre des territoires on on arrive
quasiment automatiquement à lisser les
fourchettes et je pense que même un
étudiant première année de géographie
qui écrirait une chose pareille ne
serait pas apprécié par son professeur
donc ceci ne me paraît pas un argument
d'autant plus que le problème du calcul
du PIB par région pose de graves
problèmes méthodologiques et il ne faut
surtout pas considérer la fiabilité de
ces chiffres qui te tiennent pas compte
non plus bien sûr des différence de
pouvoir d'achat selon les régions hein
ne serait-ce que en matière de coût du
foncier de l'immobilier qui est très
variable selon les territoires autre
élément donc on dit des régions
fusionnées auront davantage de de de
budget tout dépend bien entendu ce que
signifie un budget l'une des raisons de
la réussite des régions depuis
1982 c'est que justement elles ont pas
été noyées dans des service fonctionnel
assumer et donc vous savez très bien que
jusqu'à l'acte 2 de la décentralisation
la majorité des budgets régionaux
étaient des budgets d'investissement
donc il avait un rôle structurant sur le
territoire et effectivement c'était une
raison de leur efficacité euh alors que
vouloir comme cela évoqué dans une autre
loi leur confier la réparation des
robinets des collèges je dirais pourquoi
pas mais je vois pas en quoi cela relève
d'un caractère structurant dans la vie
d'un territoire c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait très bien être assumé par
exemple par les communes qui le font
très bien dans les écoles primaires ou
dans les écoles maternelles donc ma
conclusion première c'est que parler de
taille critique c'est le mot qui est
utilisé dans le projet de loi c'est
chercher un optimum régional qui
n'existe pas qui n'existe pas parce que
dans aucun pays il y a une corrélation
entre l'attractivité de région le taux
de chômage et leur taille géographique
économique ou démographique alors nous
trouvons aussi d'autres petites d'autr
petites éléments qui qui sont
contestables comme ce qui est dit sur la
Pologne comme si la Pologne aurait
diminué son nombre de régions non la
Pologne n'a pas diminué son nombre de
régions simplement lorsque la Pologne
était une démocratie populaire les
régions anciennes avaient été supprimées
et donc elle a recréé ses régions
pratiquement dans les même découpage
ancien par rapport à ce qui existait
auparavant quant à l'Espagne il est
important de préciser la loi de 2012 qui
n'a pas été citée dans le le texte et la
formule aussi de renforcement des
régions est assez surprenante puisque on
parle de renforcement des régions mais
semble-t-il par rapport aux autres
collectivités territoriales mais non par
rapport à l'état ce qui ne va pas dans
le sens de la régionalisation ni d'un
éventuel fédéralisme deuxième argument
donc avancé c'est la question des
économies sur la question des économies
je voudrais distinguer deux périodes la
période je dirais à 5 ou 6 ans la
période où l'on réalise ces fusions et
la période postérieure concernant la
première période de 5 ou 6 ans pendant
laquelle l'on réaliserait ces fusions
des régions il faut d'abord insister sur
les coûts directs qui sont inévitables
chacun c'est ici que cela suppose la
mise en place de nouveaux outils communs
que ce soit des outils en matière
d'intranet ou ou d'extranet ça suppose
des déménagements des transferts de
personnel des aménagements mais ce n'est
pas la partie peut-être la plus
inquiétante la partie la plus
inquiétante et dans laquelle nous sommes
déjà entrés ces dernières semaines c'est
ce que l'on appelle en économie les
effet externes négatif c'est-à-dire le
fait que nous allons passer beaucoup de
temps dans nos régions à discuter des
modalités des fusions à discuter du
choix des Capitals à discuter de la
localisation des services de la Région
et donc c'est un temps qui ne sera pas
consacré à réfléchir aux stratégies
régionales et au développement de
l'emploi et c'est un temps qui sera
perdu aussi pour réfléchir à un élément
qui est très important qui consiste à
renforcer les coopérations avec les
autres régions parce que même lorsqu'on
parle de la fusion des de Normandie
cette fusion des Normandies ça doit peut
être une Normandie qui se réferme sur
elle-même mais une Normandie qui passe
son temps à coopérer avec ses régions
voisines qu'elles soi française ou
européenne en plus nous avons quand même
un problème géographique qui n'existe
peu en Normandie parce que les grandes
villes de Normandie ont une proximité
géographique qui a été considérablement
accrue grâce au pont Normandie
mais dans les fusions qui sont
évoquées normalement pour qu'ell soit
efficace il faut qu'il y a une synergie
entre les anciennes capital si je
regarde Amien reince 2h26 par le train
Orléan limoge 2h7 par le train et je
n'ai pas osé dire tour limoche c'est
encore pire bien sûr toulouse-
Montpellier
2h08 clairement Lyon 2h25 donc
aujourd'hui c'est sûr nous n'avons pas
les les les les équipements ferroviaires
qui permettent de faciliter la synergie
et faire en sorte que ces villes soient
en réseau à cela bien sûr va vont
s'ajouter les couts directs permanents
c'est-à-dire le fait que bien entendu et
c'est écrit d'ailleurs dans un document
du ministère de la
décentralisation que c'est le mieux
disant qu'il emportera toujours à
l'occasion des des fusions et donc le
mieux disant ça veut dire forcément des
coups plus élevés que ce soit en matière
sociale que que ce soit dans les
dotations au lycée c'est également la
création d'antennes supplémentaires dans
les territoires et en fait l'expérience
montre que les coûts sont plutôt
croissants avec la taille ce qui risque
de se produire pardon monsieur le
professeur je pense oui s'il vous plaît
parce que pour permettre à vos collègues
d'intervenir ai je je termine mais je
vous en remercie beaucoup monsieur le
Président de m'avoir rappelé à l'ordre
voilà j'ai essay
professeur absolument impossible pour
moi j'ajouterai donc j'ajouterai
simplement effectivement la le problème
de l'identité on pourrait citer de très
très nombreux exemples qui montrent que
le développement se fait lorsque les
personnes s'identifient avec leur
territoire et le cas de l'auverne
pourrait être très intéressant à citer
alors que faire je dirais que deux mots
conclusifs monsieur le Président bah
d'abord effectivement je pense que le
diagnostic n'a pas été fait le
diagnostic des réforme antérieure le
diagnostic d'analyse comparative et le
diagnostic qui con que changer le nombre
de pièces d'un pose n'améliore pas
forcément la qualité du pose et
deuxièmement il est nécessaire en
revanche d'avancer dans des réformes de
fond qui s'appellent les réformes
fiscales qui s'appellent une véritable
décentralisation mais cela suppose sans
12e de se rappeler la phrase du grand
poète Pierre seggers l'impossible c'est
ce qui demande du temps
merci alors Monsieur Daniel
Béard monsur ah c'est comme ça qu'on
gagne du
temps monsieur pardon attendez monsur ah
oui mais je veux ne voir plus les
Monsieur Martin Vanier veuillez
m'excuser mais je vous promets d'être
bref à condition que vous m'autorisez à
être brutal
allez-y j'admire la comment dire la
bonne volonté de tous mes collègues qui
passent beaucoup de temps à discuter la
carte oui cette carte est un leure vous
êtes nombreux à le savoir
politiquement cette carte nous conduit à
65 millions de franç
a joué au grand jeu du puzzle alors que
les enjeux fondamentaux de la réforme de
nos cadres d'action public sont
ailleurs cette proposition de loi a deux
générations de retard il vous manque un
géographe autour de la table Jean-Marie
miosek a fait un très beau bouquin de
600 pages pour raconter un siècle de
propositions de la réforme des régions
en France il y a au moins 30
propositions il y en ailleurs 5 ou si
rien que pour Jean-François gravier qui
adorait ça faire des réformes de car
gravier oui bon voyez on est plutôt de
bonne volonté pour essayer de dire oui
c'est un peu comme ça non mais là plutôt
non mais là ça va faire un peu long en
train ce serait mieux l'identité un peu
bousculée ça n'est plus le sujet plus du
tout le sujet dans une société en réseau
la pertinence et la cohérence ça rentre
pas dans les périmètres le pouvoir n'est
pas dans les territoires il est dans les
réseaux ce sont les réseaux les
opérateurs de réseau qui ont mis la main
sur la gestion des grands bienens
communs ou ceux qui devrai être commun
et en partie particulier les grands
biens numériques mais aussi les biens
écosystémiques et environnementaux et
tous les biens qui servent la mobilité
et ces opérateurs de réseau peuvent être
éventuellement publics mais leur
gouvernance est bien complexe commeavons
pu la voir la semaine dernière donc pour
moi je n'ai rien à dire de cette carte
je pense qu'elle est destinée à occuper
un débat public et citoyen et collectif
dans un moment où on ne savait pas
comment le construire et donc c'est de
ce point de vuel a parfaitement réussi
son son son objectif politique premier
je n'ai guerre envie de contribuer
moi-même à à cette ce que je considère
être une comédie qui du point de vue
scientifique qui est le mien est un un
dramatique retour en arrière du niveau
je dis pas ça pour mes collègues qui ont
argumenté sur le fond mais du niveau de
compréhension de nous contemporains de
ce qu'il faut faire pour faire bouger
les choses c'est vraiment l'expression
de tout changer pour que rien ne change
la question fiscale passe à la trappe la
question du contrat démocratique qui est
à à repenser de façon fondamentale et
sans doute post territorial mais j'en
dirai pas plus il a qu'à dire des choses
sur le sujet n'est pas au rendez-vous
non plus
euh la question de la maîtrise des
réseaux et des pouvoirs des réseaux
n'est pas au rendez-vous mais nous
adorons tous non seulement redistribuer
la composition de l'équipe de France
pour le prochain match mais surtout
refaire la carte des régions je vous
assure que c'est les deux sujets
fondamentaux dans les familles et et
dans les bistr donc ce point de vue là
est atteint la seule chose que je
pourrais dire sur cette carte qui
passera dans l'état où elle passera de
toute façon la semaine où elle a ét été
annoncé nous avons eu tous les jours une
mouture différente donc nous avons
préparé autant d'argumentaires que de
cartes qui nous ont été annoncé mais
nous n'en doutons pas vous allez pouvoir
vous amuser au moins aussi bien que les
constituants mais peut-être pas dans le
même contexte avec moins de dégâts
peut-être parce que quand même ça fait
quand même pas mal de de mouvements en
France et en Europe à l'époque bon
toujours est-il que il me semble que le
vrai sujet c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire avec cette carte donc je sais que
mon collègue B va dire deux trois choses
mais en résumé je pense que la condition
de réussite de cette réforme n'est pas
dans les objets qu'elle euh prétend
saisir la cohérence de la bonne maille
le grandissement de la taille la fusion
des organismes territoriaux concerné et
cetera on est on est auut terrain et
auut front des collectivités pour
réfléchir avec ça avec elle sur ça c'est
c'est bien douloureux les conditions de
la réussite de cette réforme sont dans
tout ce qui permettra au territoires
métropole pays départements territoires
ruraux territoires de montagne
territoires littoraux et cetera et
cetera à faire leur travail dans le
fameux rendez-vous de de la coordination
et de la Coopération et quelle que soit
la maille englobante dans laquelle on
décrètera le le grand soir qui n'est
certainement pas à cet endroit-là donc
le vrai sujet c'est comment on va
continuer à travailler dans les
coopérations
interterritoriales dans des réseaux dans
des alliances dans des compétences
partagées dans des cadres transnationaux
et transfrontaliers ça c'est l'avenir ça
c'est le vrai rendez-vous moderne au 21e
siècle c'est la coordination c'est pas
la fusion dans des grandes firmes les
grandes firmes c'était au 20e siècle
mais au 21 siècle c'est pas le modèle du
tout le modèle c'est le réseau et c'est
le cluster et sur ce sujet là il
faudrait changer les règles et pas les
cartes voilà pourquoi je ne dirai rien
sur la carte merci merci
beaucoup donc Monsieur Daniel bar ai je
ne me trompe pas voyez non merci
monsieur le Président donc je prolonger
un peu le propos de mon mon collègue
Martin Vanier sur un autre
mode en effet enfin ça tombe bien qu'on
soit en bout de chaîne parce que moi je
considère que pas commencer par vous
ouis voilà voilà je pense que le plan de
table était bien fait le plan de table
était très bien fait c'était bien fait
le plan moi je me j'ai envie de répondre
à votre question hein les grandes
régions qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
grandes régions mais en aval de votre
question c'estàd que en effet moi je
pense que le découpage et l'argumentaire
qui a été donné sur le découpage c'est à
la fois la question de la pertinence et
de la puissance bon je crois que mes
collègues ont tout dit donc c'est pas la
peine qu'on reprenne là-dessus donc du
coup la la la question enfin moi j'ai
envie de la poser au futur c'est au
conditionnel c'est-à-dire que voilà de
toute façon vous allez discuter de la
carte vous allez discuter des périmètres
mais ça va se faire ça va se faire on va
vers des grandes régions et donc du
coupi la question qui m'interroge c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec ces
grandes régions en terme d'action
publique c'estd qu'est-ce que ça va
changer d'avoir des régions plus grandes
qu'avant voilà et du il me semble qu'il
y a au moins enfin il y y a y a toute
une série d'hypothèses he qu'on peut
faire à partir de là mais moi je
voudrais juste en faire deux la première
c'est euh
du point de vue du rapport à l'État et
la deuxième c'est du point de vue du
rapport à la question urbaine pour aller
vite du point de vue du rapport à l'état
les les régions alors ça va faire ça va
aussi ouvrir le débat avec mon collègue
Romain vasquier c'est les les régions il
me semble se sont constitués depuis la
décentralisation sur un modèle qui est
je dirais de de vouloir plutôt calquer
enfin se fabriquer comme des Nation hein
sur le modèle finalement de la Bretagne
hein des nations c'est-à-dire des
espaces politiques avec de
appuyer sur la notion d'identité hein et
donc elles ont toutes fabriqué des
espèces de patriotisme régional hein
quel que soit les découpages parce que
là aussi hein les découpages des années
60 avaent pas grand-chose non plus bon
et et donc du coup en terme de politique
publique d'action publique c'est un peu
compliqué alors évidemment il y a
l'Alsace il y a le nordp decalais il y a
quelques exceptions à ce que je vais
dire là mais quand même enfin je dire
quand on voit excusez-moi HERV mais
quand on voit euh que moi j'avais
travaillé sur les schémas régionaux
développement économique partout en
France euh qu'est-ce que c'est que le
l'économie des pays de Loire est-ce
qu'il y a une économie des Pays de Loire
moi je sais ce que c'est qu'une économie
du Grand Ouest je sais ce que c'est
qu'une économie du choleté ou de la
vandé mais je sais pas ce que c'est
qu'une économie des pays de Loir et donc
le fait d'avoir voulu absolument
fabriquer les régions comme des petites
nations sur sur le mode identitaire
justement et de l'espace politique à mon
avis voilà et du coup c'est ça ce qui ce
qui est en train de changer ce qui peut
changer ce qui peut changer moi
l'hypothèse que je fais c'est qu'avec
des grandes régions dans le couple état
nation les régions vont plutôt choisir
le mot état plutôt que le mot nation
c'est-à-dire qu'on va vers une
étatisation des régions une étatisation
des régions c'est-à-dire que des régions
qui vont plutôt fonctionner sur un mode
étatique et le fait qu'on leur enlève la
C générale de compét va aussi dans ce
sens-là c'est-à-dire qu'elles vont
devenir des instances plutôt de
fabrication des grandes politiques
publiques et du coup il me semble que la
question que ça pose et et qui pourrait
être un objet de réflexion du légis
ateur c'est qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
d'avoir deux niveaux étatiques l'État et
les régions étatisées si je puis dire et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire du point de
vue de le du rapport de l'un à l'autre
c'estd que vous savez qu'il y a
aujourd'hui un instrument enfin qui est
en plus d'actualité c'est celui des
contrats de plan étatrégion dont on sait
bien que ça sert à rien aujourd'hui mais
et qui et qui qui a toujours fonctionné
sur un mode qui qui est un mode bottom
up top top down c'estàdire que en gros
les l'État se sert des régions comme
sous-traitant pour la mise en œuvre de
ces politiques publiques et moi je me
demande si si on va vers une étatisation
des régions hein comme l'hypothèse que
je formule là est-ce que du coup l'enjeu
c'est pas effectivement de de faire
monter la notion de contrat de plan et
ta région c'est-à-dire que les régions
soient pas simplement des sous-traitants
des politiques de l'État mais soi aussi
des contributrices aux politiques de
l'État et on cite toujours l'exemple de
l'Allemagne et ben en Allemagne on a
aujourd'hui des pacts entre l' lande et
et l'État sur la mise en œuvre des
grandes politiques de développement
économique où chaque grande région dit
en gros ce qu'elle va faire au service
des politiques étatiques il me semble
que c'est autre chose de dire en quoi
une grande région de l'Ouest dans un
découpage qu'on connaît pas encore mais
dans une grande région de l'Ouest peut
contribuer je dirais au au développement
de la France plutôt que de savoir ce que
c'est encore une fois que l'économie de
la région paysloire quoi voilà donc
c'est cette question là et donc du coup
si on va dans ce sensl deuxème deuxème
enjeu il me semble
c'est que il faut peut-être aller vers
des encore plus grandes régions alors
non pas au niveau du découpage
institutionnel mais pour reprendre ce
qui était évoqué c'estàd que des la
question des coopération renforcé
interrégional si je prends l'est là pour
changer qu'on fasse l'alsas ou la Loren
je sais pas si ça se fera et qu'on fasse
franchecé Bourgogne pourquoi pas mais
d'un du point de vue du système
productif français la question du grand
test est une question qui se pose du
grand test c'estàd avec ces quatre
régions là et donc du coup est-ce qu'on
est capable au-delà de la réforme de la
carte régionale de fabriquer des des
systèmes de coopération renforcé dans
l'esprit voilà d'un rapport entre deux
niveaux étatisés si je puis dire l'État
nation et l'État régionalisé enfin les
régions étatisé ça c'est la première
question la deuxième question c'est
c'est celle du rapport entre les régions
et les villes un peu dans dans la suite
de ce qu'a dit Jacques Levy tout à
l'heure pourquoi parce que on est dans
le la rhétorique moderniste française
depuis les années 60 sur l'hypothèse que
les régions et les villes c'est le
couple modernisateur de du territoire en
France sauf qu'on sait que justement
dans la période qui qui qui vient de
s'écoulé ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça
ça ne fonctionne pas comme ça parce que
on a confondu la notion de
métropole de puissance urbaine avec la
notion de capitale régionale hein Amien
métropole hein euh bon et donc du coup
on est dans une espèce de dialectique
entre la la la montée en puissance d'un
point de vue socioéconomique que des
territoires urbains et la concurrence
des pouvoirs entre le pouvoir urbain et
le pouvoir régional aujourd'hui on sait
bien l'exemple le le plus caricatural
que tout le monde connaît hein c'est la
més-entente publique entre le président
de la Région ronalpe et le président du
Grand lon mais je citais Amien enfin
dans tous les cas de figure on a ça et
donc il me semble que le fait qu'on
aille vers des plus grand des grandes
régions c'est une façon de recomposer le
rapport entre enfin qui qui est
aujourd'hui un rapport faussement
conflictuel entre région et capitale
régionale et d'avoir en fait de de lui
substituer un rapport entre région et
réseau métropolitain hein je prends
l'exemple Auvergne ronalpe ben si on
fait si on va vers une région Auvergne
ronalp ça change la donne d'une part
parce que ça renforce encore plus le
discours de Jean-Jacques eran
c'està-dire l'idée que il y a il est pas
uniquement dans un rapport exclusif avec
Lyon mais que il a en face de lui alors
lui il dit trois métropoles je sais plus
qui disait deux mais il disait trois en
parlant puisqu pas tu es
Suisse hein de de la métropole
jeunevoise euh plutôt c'est plutôt Lyon
qui est une ban lieue de Genève voilà
hein voilà et et et et d'autre part ça
ça ça organise un système métropolitain
lyonnais qui va jusqu'à clarmontferrand
en effet et sur lesquels du coup le
rapport ent les fonctions spécifiques
les rôles de la région et du pouvoir
urbain peuvent peut-être se spécifier
davantage donc je je ne suis pas du tout
hein je suis comme mes collègues
extrêmement sceptique sur sur la
révision de cette carte mais je pense
que si on prend au pied de la lettre la
la la le le fait de fabriquer des
grandes régions il peut y avoir des
ouvertures sur lequelles il me semble
qu'il y a des enjeux de travaux tant
législatifs qu'ensuite pratique si je
puis dire pour lui donner du sens mais
ce sens il est ni dans la puissance ni
dans la
pertinence merci
beaucoup alors
monsieur Pasquier romain Pasquier on m'a
dit que vous étiez vous êtes directeur
de recherche au CNRS mais vous
intéressez à la Bretagne on m'a dit de
temps en temps de temps en temps à mes
heures perdues voilà voilà euh mais je
suis pas venu pour parler de la Bretagne
mais je peux vous en parler mais vous
vous pouvez en parler il y en a d'A qui
l'ont fait hein d'cord
euhin non bon moi je crois euh tout
d'abord merci de d'avoir bien
voulu m'écouter m'auditionner avec mes
collègues euh bon je vais pas parler non
plus de la carte je pense
que je crois que c'est une faute de
méthodeésement quelquesuns en ont parlé
parce qu'on serait désespéré oui je vais
vous en parler quand même mais je crois
qu'effectivement c'est une faute de
méthode majeure d'avoir commencé par la
carte alors on voit bien pourquoi parce
que c'était facile parce qu'il fallait
une loi ordinaire parce que on pouvait
assez aisément donner à penser qu'on
avait de l'autorité
politique mais je je crois que ça bloque
toute une série d'autres
sujets et que le risque d'ensablement de
la réforme est est d'autant plus grand
avec cette entrée méthodologique par la
carte donc la carte des régions je n'en
parlerai pas beaucoup simplement moi je
suis quand même assez en désaccord avec
mon collègue Hervé lebz sur l'idée que
voilà il faut tout faire pour se
préserver des identités comme si les
Bretons étaient prêt prendre d'assut je
ne sais
quel je ne sais quel
oui a par les Bonny rouges mais enfin je
ne sais quel forteresse autour des des
marches historiques de la Bretagne moi
je pense que l'identité c'est quelque
chose de très ouvert il y en a beaucoup
des identité en France et heureusement
et
qu'elles qu'elles aident à bâtir des
projets de territoire hein et que les
identités on le voit dans toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion publique Bretagne y
comprise en France sont des idtités sont
pas exclusives c'està-dire que ce sont
pas des identités catalanes ou
écossaises où on se sent écossais et pas
britannique où on se sent catalan et pas
espagnol un Breton qu'est-ce qu'il est
il est breton et français à 75 % celui
qui se sent exclusivement breton dans
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion publique
depuis 30 ans c'est 1 % donc vous voyez
il faut il faut arrêter de jouer à se
faire peur à moins d'être missionné par
jacquesxiette mais autrement voilà faut
pas se faire peur hein donc s'il y avait
quelque chose s'il y avait quelque chose
à dire sur la carte et donc là aussi je
suis en désaccord avec arvelobz il faut
supprimer une chose dans la carte c'est
les Pays de la Loire et beaucoup de
choses seraient résolu on aurait
monsieur Sueur le Val de
Loire mais le seul problème c'est les
Pays de la Loire il faut voilà donc moi
je pense qu'il faut rattacher la maïenne
et la Loire Atlantique à la Bretagne je
suis désolé nous vous
donnons le Méloir la Sart voilà et je
pense que la Vendé on peut la laisser
toute seule alors je crois que le
sénateur de vandé n'est plus là mais à
mon avis après avoir lu beaucoup
d'économistes et de sociologues la Vendé
fait système territorial en tant que tel
elle n'a pas besoin d'être rattaché à
une grande région ni à poitoucharant ni
à la
Bretagne et oui mais je crois que sur le
plan économique sur le plan politique
sur le plan social elle fait système
elle a pas besoin d'une grande tutelle
régionale donc ça c'était mon mot sur la
carte je suis désolé mais il fallait le
dire quand même hein euh alors si on
veut vraiment donner du sens à la
réforme à mon avis il faut raisonner
différemment ça a déjà été dit donc je
vais aller très vite et tout est résumé
dans ce petit rapport que j'ai publié la
semaine dernière réussir la région au
service du citoyen de la croissance et
de la République qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire euh malheureusement pour le faire
il faudrait sans doute modifier un peu
la Constitution si on veut aller assez
loin on le fera
pas il faudrait sans doute modifier
l'article 72 sur la tutelle l'article 20
sur le pouvoir règlementaire bon donc on
le fera pas bon simplement quand même il
me faut à mon avis pour avoir un pouvoir
régional je crois que c'est un peu le
sens de la réforme tout de même j'ai
l'impression il faut des compétences et
des Finances pour le moment en compéten
on a les collèges et les route
départementale ça fait peu pour être
compétitif pour être des acteurs globaux
hein si on commence à raisonner sur le
transfert de P l'emploi aux régions ah
là on commence à toucher à des choses
qui commencent à être intéressantes pour
des régions hein si on parle de
l'enseignement supérieur si on parle de
la régionalisation de la
BPI là effectivement on touche à des
outilsin
d'aménagement de développement
économique qui pourrait être intéressant
et puis il faudrait évidemment une marge
de manœuvre sur les dispositifs mais
pour ça il faudrait un pouvoir
réglementaire de plein exercice pour les
régions ce qu'elles n'ont pas elles
n'auront que deux schémas qui pourrai
être prescriptifs tout dépendra de votre
travail mais si ça prend autant de temps
que l'élaboration du zdrifil de
France ça risque d'être compliqué en
terme d'efficacité et et d'efficience et
de de diminution des coûts de
transaction pour le coup hein donc je
suis assez dubitatif et puis sur les
finances bah c'est le c'est le c'est le
grand trou noir là si on regarde du côté
des Lander allemand bon c'est ou ou des
des communautés autonomes espagnoles bah
c'est une part de la TVA est-ce qu'on
est prêt à donner une part de la TVA aux
régions c'est c'est clairement ça qu'il
faut se poser comme question voilà là on
donne un levier là on donne une capacité
à agir hein bon
euh autre chose on les oublie souvent
dans nos débats les citoyens qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent les citoyens moi je pense
qu'il faut des outils aussi de
renforcement de la démocratie locale et
régionale et moi je propose si on va
vers le pouvoir régional d'instaurer un
parlementarisme régional qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est le model Corse c'est-à-dire
laassission de l'exécutif et du
législatif hein que l'assemblée
régionale
ou qu'elle soit donne sa confiance à un
gouvernement régional à un exécutif on
sait le faire en France on le fait en
Corse on le fait en Nouvelle-Calédonie
on le fait en voilà pourquoi ne le
feraiton pas pour alors avec un autre
élément Jean-Pierre rafarin l'avait
évoqué en son temps à mon avis c'est
décloisonner les temps électoraux entre
les régions de pas avoir ce
système universaliste où toutes les
régions doivent se tenir en même temps
ce serait une vraie richesse pour notre
pays d'avoir un éclairage sur les enjeux
politiques régionaux en mini Pyréné en
Bretagne en champagne-arden et cetera
hein plutôt que de faire des élections
régionales qui soit en fait un test
national donc là le parlementarisme
régional ce serait intéressant et puis
désolé messieurs les élus mais ça nous
permettrait quoi ça nous permettrait
dans des gouvernements régionaux d'y
inclure des des personnes qui ne sont
pas issu du monde politique hein de la
société civile hein donc ça ça serait
une une petite richesse à côté des élus
hein donc ça à mon avis ça serait une
avancée assez
intéressante et puis j'ai envie de dire
un droit à la
différenciation moi je pense beaucoup je
crois beaucoup et donc là je reviens au
cas breton à la collectivité unique je
pense que ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
faciliter la fusion entre conseils
généraux et conseils régionaux à carte
régionale constante
hein par exemple moi j'était pas contre
le conseiller territorial c'était une
étape effectivement
hein et donc il faut continuer sur la
voie alsacienne mais en facilitant le le
le travail des élus et pas en
transformant ce ce genre de procédure en
une course à obstacle impossible donc il
faut là j'en appelle à vous
parlementaire
faciliter les les possibilités
fluidifier le passage à la collectivité
unique alors attention je suis d'accord
avec un de mes collègues ça ne sera plus
possible sur la région midipyranée
langdoc ce ne sera possible que dans des
régions qui vont rester à taille humaine
entre guillemets
hein donc voilà donc je crois qu'un
droit à la différenciation à
l'autoorganisation locale une réforme
ascendante plutôt que pseudo jacobine
aura été de bien meilleur augure je vous
remercie bien
oui bon on suspend les travaux pour 6
mois oui d'abord oui d'abord il y a il y
a tout un tas de raisons on nous a
expliqué que avant de créer les
départements on a mis 6 mois mais on
faisait aussi des lois on se précipitait
pas pour faire les lois parce que nous
on va de plus en plus vite donc on en
fait de plus en plus et elles sont de
plus en plus mauvais c'est bien connu de
toute façon la
qualité puis on les applique pas parce
que dès qu'elles sont voté on en fait
une autre de toute façon c'est
formidable alors donc rassurez-vous mais
en T les cas messieurs vraiment nous
vous remercions infiniment parce que les
points de vue différents mais en même
temps nous ont quand
même donner je crois à certains des
idées hein et et et et nous ont nous ont
ouvert des perspectives sur peut-être
une d'autres méthodes de
fabrication d'une
réforme moi je suis hélas
francilien je sais pas ce que c'est par
contre ce que je sais je suis la grande
couronne j'habite au fin fond de du du
canton de châteauandon vous voyez à 3 km
de la future Région Poitou char centre
je sais pas quoi bon et je me dis quand
même que quelquefois si on veut imposer
des choses les gens le sentent pas et je
sais plus qui a dit il y a même une
identité en scène saint il y a c'est
vous qui l'avez dit le premier et que il
faut pas quand même complètement
négliger tout ça c'est même si elles
sont récentes par contre on peut se
poser la question et
notamment est-ce qu'il faut garder les
départements de la la petite couronne
ou est-ce qu'il faut faire une métropole
qui fusionnerait Paris et les
départements de la petite couronne
plutôt non parce que les missions les
fonction et cetera plutôt que créer
cette métropole que nous avons créé par
la loi enfin qu'on va qu'on a préfiguré
qu'est-ce que ça va devenir ça rien à
voir avec le projet d'aujourd'hui mais
c'est quand même le projet de demain
parce qu'on peut pas dire que les
métropoles n'auront pas une action sur
les régions et de poser la question que
des régions ou de la taille sans parler
des métropoles et je sais plus qu' l'a
dit mais évidemment ronalpe avec Lyon
qui est à la fois département métropole
développement économique et tout comment
ça va s'articuler les deux
collectivités collectivités sont des
vraies questions sur lesquelles on
aurait encore beaucoup à vous entendre
en tous les cas merci beaucoup
messieurs voilà pour cette audition qui
s'est déroulé donc la semaine dernière
au Sénat c'était les derniers travaux
préparatoires de la Commission spéciale
sur la délimitation des régions qui
travaillent donc sur la première partie
de la réforme territoriale vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site sur
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 15h avec
perinna en direct et le début de
l'examen ici au Sénat de cette première
partie de la réforme territoriale de ce
projet de loi sur la délimitation des
régions et on commencera très fort
puisqu'il y aura une motion référendaire
une motion qui demande un référendum sur
ce texte et l'arrêt de l'examen du texte
au Parlement très bonne fin de journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires